il faut faire monter mon compte twitter
parce que je regarde et vous avez tous
deux ou trois millions de twitter et moi
comme une merde je cent mille noms alors
tu es mal alors tu es une merde oui mais
je t'aime comme ça va encore laurent
laurent tu as combien sambi l'on peut
regarder on peut regarder le compte de
laurent voulait nous donner des chiffres
exacts 726 1868 les cherry à 3,6 vous
aimez laurent baffie si vous aimez
touche pas à mon poste
j'aime on aimerait quoi vous voulez
monte à combien l'oréal fans les majors
là je vous annonce que si j'arrive à un
million le million
je viens une semaine gratuitement vous
donnerais tu à une oeuvre le 26 nov oui
je viendrai une semaine gratuitement
chez vous donc je suis récurer oui je
jure mais non on peut pas faire un truc
là aujourd'hui un truc même impossible
gens ont dit à 200 milles de renverser
974 on a le temps frérot me mettre un
nom andré vim oui mais si on arrive à
200 milles avant l'émission tu reviens
demain gratuit demain d'accord à jour 5
mars honda crz sambi avant l'émission
[Applaudissements]
regardez est ce que laurent sera là
demain tous
[Applaudissements]